freunde keine ahnung was das ist was das
darstellen soll
aber es ist einfach so eine kranke katze
hallo meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen zu einer neuen folge der
minecraft werkzeug am dienstag
ich habe den geräten immer wieder eine
folge auch weil die komponenten dienste
deswegen habe ich mir ausgesucht und ich
würde mich freuen den bis zum ende dran
ich würde mich freuen wenn das wieder am
ende bewertet und ich freue mich über
alles was immer ich bin ein freudiger
menschen deswegen fangen wir an mit fact
nummer mc nummer eins hat etwas mit dem
shader zu tun nicht gerade benutzt und
zumindest bei dem crusader ist es so
also es ist ein fakt über diesen crew
das shader den ich benutze das fragen
mich einmal viele erwarten shader das
ist der hier auch übrigens derzeit ist
ja mal wieder unfassbar toll
irgendwie es jeder sieht und was wird
all den ich irgendwie oder ich finde
jeden zieht unfassbar das heißt da wir
den zieht aber ihr könnt ihr mal also
ihr wisst ja denke ich wenn ich
irgendwie portieren stehe und ich gehe
ins pause menü bleiben die tiere einfach
so stehen selbst wenn ein tier gerade
geschlagen hat oder sogar website kurz
in der luft stehen und dann geht das
ganze weiter dass es allerdings bei dem
shader zwar auch so mit den tieren aber
wenn ihr mal hier auf das auf die
pflanzen und so weiter achtet die
bewegen sich weiter und auch das wasser
hier vorne also hier ist ein bewegendes
scharf ich drücke auf pause das schaf
bleibt stehen aber das wasser hier
bewegt sich und das gras hier vorne
da ist jetzt eventuell die face camp vor
aber das bewegt auch so ein bisschen
weiter hier sieht man das denke ich noch
mal ein bisschen besser mit den medas
spieler die fans kämpferisch besser da
da sie das da bewegt sich das ist der
effekt nummer 1 kein richtiger minecraft
fact aber ein fake über diesen shader in
minecraft und der shader ist für
minecraft macht also ist es irgendwie
doch minecraft jedenfalls das werk
nummer 1 und nummer 2 wo freunde ich
schieße gerade auf diesen blog hier
relativ viele pfeile drauf und ich habe
keine rüstung an das heißt eigentlich
müsste ich wenn ich mich da drunter
stellen und alle pfeile irgendwie auf
mich draufgehen müsste ich davon locker
sterben weil das sind jetzt locker schon
zehn stück oder so das könnt ihr hier
einfach nochmal sehen da sind schon mega
viele pfeile am drinstecken
das heißt ich gehe jetzt mal eben hier
drunter ag in den game mode 0
und normalerweise müsste ich ja jetzt
sterben allerdings wenn ich mal einmal
einen teil ab
seht ihr schon ich werde quasi nur von
einem pfeil getroffen der da auf mich
drauf liegt und den rest der ist dann
einfach quasi fliegt an mir vorbei weil
der eine mich zur seite drängt das heißt
ich habe gerade irgendwie ein herz
neun oder so von dem ein teil der oben
runter gefallen ist obwohl ich
eigentlich von jedem fall ein herz hätte
abgezogen werden müssen tun und nicht in
die zehen herzen verloren als sich wer
gestorben also viele pfeile die auf
einem blog über einem sind und
überfallen dann runter fallen
davon wird man dann immer nur vom allem
getroffen und da braucht er dann keine
angst haben wenn ihr unter seinem blog
mein laptop ist gerade irgendwie
verrutscht begeistert so freunde ihr
kennt es ich habe hier einen
dorfbewohner und ich setze hier jetzt
beispielsweise meinen villiger weg der
willicher wird direkt vor dem
dorfbewohner weglaufen weil der dorfweil
weil der der willicher wird vor dem
zombie weglaufen weil der zombie ja
laufen kann und somit den willicher
töten möchte soll ich jetzt allerdings
mal hier vorne einen zombie hinsetze und
denen ein mein card setzte dann kann er
sicher natürlich eigentlich nicht
bewegen also der bleibt ganz herzlich
könnten jetzt schlagen boxen et cetera
pp
er bewegt sich nicht alle da müsste man
sich eigentlich denken dass die billiger
das ist denen scheißegal ist dass da
einer ist also dass da irgendwie so ein
zombie halt sitzt weil der der sitze
halten ohne der macht der nächste
schildern warum aber wenn ich hier ganz
ganz viele bilder jam ums vorne werdet
ihr schon sehen die schreien auch wieder
alle rum und laufen alle vor diesem
zombie weg das ist nicht egal also das
ist egal dass da hinten jetzt auch noch
andere zombies sind vor denen die
eventuell weglaufen können aber die
laufen ja erst mal von diesem kombi in
alle richtungen weg und das finde ich
ein bisschen komisch weil dieser zombie
kann eigentlich gar nichts machen das
ist ein bisschen verwirrend hätte dass
sich auch die sonne ritual irgendwie so
recht eine fackel links nimmt fackel
dann ist da einfach so einen zombie in
summe ein kart drin
ach übrigens falls sich irgendwer fragt
wieso ich eventuell zum blass wirkte das
wort in letzter zeit so voll häufig
einfach in die kommentare geschrieben
ich habe jetzt einfach eine neue
belichtung dahinten hingestellt und
allgemein kriegt man ja im winter nicht
so viel sonne aber ich bin jetzt nicht
irgendwie dass ich nur noch in der bude
sitze und drogenabhängig bin oder so
weil ich so bleiben blass bin sondern
einfach weil die belichtung bisschen
anders ist und deswegen ich weiß nicht
ich finde so besser weil vorher war das
nur so komisch habe ich das mit dieser
lampe lampen mit dieser lampe habe ich
mich beleuchtet aber wenn ich die man
macht sich schon das licht von dieser
lampe ist okay sind wahrscheinlich gar
nicht aber das ist so gelblicht wenn ich
mich damit wohl auch wenn ich mich damit
an leuchtet dann bin ich so von der
einen seite mega grell und von der
anderen seite so gelblich und das ist
eigentlich total unnötig deswegen habe
ich mir jetzt eine neue form der
beleuchtung sucht deswegen bin ich so
ja so freunde ich habe hier ein zombie
der volk wollte villiger aber ich möchte
euch etwas zeigen und zwar wenn ich mal
times at 0 mache verbrennen ja zombies
wenn ich dann allerdings eine feier
resistance porsche auf den drauf
schmeiße dann hat er zwar trotz noch
diese feuerwehr blabla und kann auch
noch andere mit dem feuer anstecken aber
er selbst gegen feuer nicht mehr
allergisch
da denkt man sich erstmal so ja sehr
klar dass leider nicht verbrennt und zu
aber ich finds ehrlich gesagt unter auf
zwei aspekte bezogen sehr sehr komisch
und zwar erst eine feuer resistenz und
sollte eigentlich jetzt nicht brennen
allerdings wenn er in den brennenden
zustand obwohl er eigentlich gar nicht
mehr brennt ein zombie ein williger
angreift dann seht ihr schon fängt
dieser villiger auch an video verfolgt
nicht nur ihn
was was hell was hat er gegen diesen
einen village malta da sind so viel und
der verfolgt nur ein also keine ahnung
deswegen kann ich euch das gerade
irgendwie nicht zeigen was meine doch
jetzt vielleicht anders viel zu schnell
hell wie komisch und also dass auf jeden
fall ein erster spectors kann irgendwie
nicht zeigen weil er nur den einen
billiger hier verfolgt und der zweite
aspekt ist einfach das ist ein bisschen
komisch und zweier diese feuer resistenz
aber die sonne ist ja eigentlich ich
weiß nicht also wenn wenn ich kann ja
auch sein überleben aber der zombie
nicht und natürlich wenn er jetzt durch
feuer durch läuft wenn ich den antun
würde würde das natürlich auch überleben
aber ich finds ein bisschen aber jetzt
aber ich finds halt bisschen komisch so
feuer resistent weil er dann resistent
ist gegenüber der sonne das ist ein
bisschen was es nun dass sie eigentlich
achter sind kühl bis ich dachte es wären
so komisch es hat mich aus an die
command folgender mit denen mit den
luftballons
aber naja ich hoffe ihr habt in dem
defekt irgendwie verstanden auf effekt
nummer vier
und jetzt kommen jetzt schon zum letzten
takt und da wechseln wir mal eben die
version so freunde da sind wir auch
schon und zwar befinden wir uns hier in
der minecraft alf ahrens punkt null
punkten null punkt 11 und das tut mir
zugesendet vom vom david oder so glaube
ich ich vergesse letzter zeit immer
diesen namen zu erwähnen
und zwar ist es einfach eine ganz
kuriose sache ich wusste überhaupt gar
nicht mehr dass man diese alpha sache
überhaupt noch spielen kann mit diesem
neuen minecraft launcher und zwar laufen
hier kleine steves rum und jetzt schaut
euch mal an wie die rumlaufen freunde
keine ahnung was das ist was das
darstellen soll
aber es ist einfach so eine kranke packe
ich verstehe das nicht also
hat den effekt auch nur so beschrieben
ja nimmer die alphaversion und schaue
deal auf animationen von steve an
bei ihm läuft würde ich sagen vor allem
dann ist man mal so aufgefallen in
dieser version
man kann mit recht keine blöcke setzen
sondern mit rechts ich nur sagen okay
block setzen oder abbauen das heißt wenn
ich recht einmal drücken kann ich jetzt
hier blöcke hinsetzen widerrechtlich und
dann gehts weg und jemand kann ich mich
quasi jetzt untergraben aber es gibt
einfach nichts außer erde und steinen
und ich glaube sogar wenn ich jetzt ganz
weit wie komme ich jetzt wieder hoch
also die welt ist auch begrenzt
dieser version ich habe glaube ich ein
kleines problem okay wenn ich mich
umschaue
es passiert einfach nichts aber das soll
uns nicht stören
660 verzichten ist ja keine ahnung was
davon jetzt halten soll ich kann ja auch
nicht entgehen ich kann ja auch nicht
auch wenn ich es kate drücke dann dann
lädt das ganze unterstützt ab einfach
also das ist eine alphaversion da kann
man ja auch nicht viel erwarten
aber ich wollte euch nur diesel auf
animation von steve zeigen das habe ich
jetzt geschafft und will diese hat man
das fake nummer 5 eigentlich will ich
euch da gern noch ein bisschen mehr
zeigen aber irgendwie geht es jetzt
gerade nicht mehr
deswegen würde ich mich einfach freunde
des video bewertet wir sehen uns
eventuell will in der nächsten woche
wieder bei den mai kraftwerks oder
freitag bei den komanis oder irgend
einem anderen video und dann wünschen
wunderschönen tag
achso übrigens freunde ich bin zur zeit
mit dem gedanken am spielen sondern sein
buch anzufertigen also ich war da immer
so ein bisschen gegen ich habe das zwar
nie glaube ich in einem video geäußert
dass ich dagegen bin aber ich war immer
so dagegen wenn man wendet wenn einfach
irgendwelche youtuber songs gemacht
haben und einfach überhaupt nicht singen
konnten oder irgendwie sowas
deswegen werde ich wahrscheinlich
einfach so ein buch machen wo ich die
ganzen sachen in minecraft wie ich finde
einfach vorstelle ich weiß das wird
jetzt ein bisschen komisch an und wenn
ihr sagt nee das ist scheiße dann mache
ich das natürlich auch nicht wenn da
keiner von der idee begeistert ist aber
es wird dann einfach weise nicht so
aussehen wie das nicht so ein paar
päckchen schreibe vielleicht auf ex die
ich noch nicht in videos genannt habe
ganz viele commerce oder sogar dann
sieht die ich am geilsten finde die
besten skins dann irgendwie noch
vielleicht so eine kleine story wie ich
zu minecraft gekommen bin vielleicht
auch so ein paar bilder oder keine
ahnung in die sowas integrierten will
mit erhalten und zur zeit am gedanken
machen weil ich mit dem gedanken
gespielt habe euch mal irgendwie sowas
zu geben und
keine ahnung also nur ganz grobe frage
wer tier dafür oder dagegen also was
haltet ihr von dieser idee da wirklich
eure meinung auf jeden fall mega
interessieren und jetzt lasst ihr euch
in ruhe jetzt
verpisst euch ich möchte man einfach
hier ok
luca fazit nie wieder runter schmeißen
ist alles wieder in ordnung geht steht
oder nicht